Joining me today is an author,
a screenwriter,
the host of the Andrew Klavan show,
and one of the few same people on the
Internet.
Andrew Klavan.
Welcome back to the Rubin report.
Thank you.
It's nice to be here.
I love your new studio.
Thanks.
Well,
you are one of the last guests before we
built this home studio,
and we had you on at a very odd time
because it was right before the
election,
but we were going to air it after the
election because I had to pad some shows
because we were,
we were building this.
So I,
and perhaps you too,
when on the assumption that Hillary was
gonna win and a,
and then people immediately after we
heard it said,
you got to get Cleveland back on because
you guys got to,
got to clean this whole thing up.
So you're ready to do some cleaning?
I'm ready.
I'm here.
All right.
So where I want to start first is I do
consider you one of the few sane people
that I,
that speaks ill of view,
but I consistently,
every time I watch one of your clips or
I see what you're tweeting about,
you strike me as just,
you basically striked me as decent,
which these days I think has a
correlation between decency,
insanity.
Uh,
that's a lot of pressure I'm giving,
you know,
is right.
It is sad that being decent actually
elevates you heard these days.
But if,
but you know,
it,
it's the thing with me is that I have,
I can say I can state with my principals
are I can I fall,
I tried to follow my principals and I
try not to get too mixed up with
personalities,
which in this day and age with a
president like trump,
with like the people around you know,
around him makes things a lot clearer.
You know,
because that's what people are paying
attention to.
They're paying attention to the big
faces,
the paying attention to that.
He said this and she said that,
and I'm just like trying to follow that
principle.
Would I know what it is and I'm trying
to follow that thing.
Yeah.
So I think I come from a similar place
and I think you know,
our politics,
which do line up in a lot of ways,
not,
not fully,
but that that's what I try to go for.
Where do you think that comes from
within you that you don't go for all of
that other stuff that,
that so many people do well in me is
actually a matter of time or observing
over time what works,
what doesn't work.
And also,
you know,
it's just been a basic,
maybe it was the time I was raised in,
but it has been a basic principle of me,
that peace of mind that people should be
free.
That you should be fruit,
that you are,
you know,
made by God to be a free person.
That the things that are happening
inside you that are expressed in your,
and the things that you like and the
things that you want to say and your
opinions on that,
all of those things are a uniquely
valuable.
And even if you're a jackass,
even if you're saying stuff that makes
me want to strangle you,
you know,
if you're a racist or something like
this,
I think that there's something uniquely
valuable bull about that.
And I know that it's more important than
some guy in Washington who knows better
than you.
And I think that that's,
that's always been my assumption.
It was,
I was raised in that all American way.
I was raised in the suburbs and the
early sixties you know,
it's just,
that was kind of what that was the civic
religion and it always good to me and
the,
when things changed I would listen to
the arguments and I fall,
I've changed you.
I've developed and that things get are
different over time,
but certain principles stay the same and
if you stick with that you basically,
I don't know,
you know,
it's,
it's a question of actually enjoying
other people and even when they can be
jerks.
Sometimes I like them,
you know,
I'd like you can enjoy sitting across
from someone that you don't agree with
you saying that,
that you can do that.
This is the thing.
When you don't,
whenever I see on Youtube,
it says so and so destroys someone else
says so and so talks to someone else and
big letters,
you know,
because yeah,
when you talk to people you disagree
with,
if they don't get angry at you and
they're not shouting at you,
you know,
you learn a lot of stuff and he can and,
and you hone your own arguments and
sometimes on occasion you change your
mind.
I mean,
I'm a,
I would say if I had to place myself on
the political spectrum,
I'd be a libertarian,
but one of the reasons I changed on
abortion took 20 years,
but I had an argument with a guy and I
lost it and I thought like,
you know what?
I can't defend my position against this
guy,
which is a great teachable moment.
It's a real teachable moment that it
reminds you to listen to people.
Yeah.
I like that you just used the phrase
civic religion because one of the things
I've been talking about on here is that
to me,
leftism has become a secular religion.
Yes.
I've had a couple of people mentioned
this idea of Peter,
but goes in what's on a couple of weeks
ago,
uh,
who really explained it well,
but that basically this has become this
infallible doctrine that you must never
leave.
And if you do leave you're going to
basically have a fat wallet on your
head.
Right.
But a civic religion is,
is an interesting phrase because
basically you were just,
your civic religion in that regard was
just live and let live.
But we're pretty much,
yes basically.
And the idea that you know that the more
government there is,
the less of a person there is,
you know,
that the fact that a woman comes into a
town and says,
oh I know how to do people's hair and
the government says we need a permit for
that permit to do hair.
Do you know that that's,
it's just a kind of ongoing,
he's a bald guy issue.
Right,
exactly.
You know,
you read those occasional stories where
some little kid has a lemonade stand and
the police pull up,
you know,
cause he doesn't have a permit.
I mean that is the stuff that is so
offensive to me and,
and it's like I guess over time I've
kept watching people who told me that
they were trying to make the world more
free and more fair,
but it always turned out,
not always,
but it often turned out that what they
were really trying to do is take the
power away from someone they thought was
a pressing them and take it themselves
so that they could oppress a person who
had been oppressing.
And I have like just steadfastly
maintained that like I want the world to
be more free and more fair.
I'm perfectly willing to accept that
somebody has been marginalized and needs
to be included,
but I'm not willing to force this other
guy to like it or to include them or do
serve him or do anything else.
It just seems to me that freedom is a
balance.
Yeah.
You mentioned something very briefly,
God now,
last time you were on.
Yeah,
we,
we did sort of your whole evolution,
which is really kind of fascinating.
You were born Jewish,
then you are atheist.
For what a bulk of your five years.
For 35 years.
GNOSTIC atheist.
And then about how old were you when you
then I was,
I was about 45 when I became an atheist
when I start to believe in God and I was
just about 50 when I was baptized down.
Yeah.
So how,
I just had,
uh,
your friend Dennis prager on,
hey,
my friend Dennis prager and,
and Michael Shermer,
you know Michael Michael who runs a
skeptic magazine.
Oh yes.
And we had a great conversation about
belief and morality with God or without
God.
It was really great.
And at the end we all agreed,
wow,
how nice.
We can sit in a room and not agree on
everything and we might have dinner
together,
you know?
Um,
but for,
for you as someone that's traveled in
and out of religion,
uh,
how important is the idea of religion as
a foundational belief for society?
Well,
the only reason to believe in religion
as far as I'm concerned is because it's
true.
Okay.
That's the only reason.
So the idea that it's good for society
or it is,
um,
or conducive to law and order are
conducive to politeness.
And I'm not interested in believing in a
fantasy just because it works.
I,
and I've always hated arguments based on
practicality when it comes to
metaphysics.
You know,
to me,
uh,
you can be a nice person and obviously
without being,
without being a theorist at all,
plenty of Nice atheists are lovely
people who are atheists.
But,
but I do believe that most of what you
think is true is illogical.
Without religion,
without God.
And many people don't follow their own
thoughts down to the ground.
And this is true of both atheists and
believers.
And I do believe that.
Here's what I think has happened to us.
I think that,
you know,
right around the 17th century,
the science became science.
We the of what we know it to be and
certain questions were put aside in
order to do science.
So in other words,
you had people saying,
Hey,
I can measure this and I can predict
this and then I can heal this and I can
build this and all these things are such
a great,
you know,
obviously such a great benefit.
This is idea from the iphone,
the penicillin,
whatever you're talking about.
All this stuff has revolutionized human
life.
It was assumed and it was argued that
there was an underlying logic to science
which precluded God which eliminated
God.
Even though most of the people who
invented science,
we're Christians,
there was presumed that there was an
underlying logic.
So in other words,
they say there's evolution and if
there's evolution,
everything is random and you go,
well,
okay,
there's evolution but random,
you can't tell randomness from within a
system.
You can't say I'm in a system and is
random because obviously the order of
every system comes from outside the
system.
I believe that logic is starting to
collapse.
I believe that logic has played out and
I believe it has been to us in the
materialism that basically materialism,
that everything is material.
Everything has a material because the
material explanation is better than
that.
That I believe is toxic because it
doesn't make sense because you cannot
get from morality to materialism and
from materialism to morality that I
believe has had a toxic effect on our
society.
And so I don't want to replace
materialism with theism because I think
it's toxic.
I want to do it because I think the
truth is healing and liberating.
So without going too far down,
just specifically the rabbit hole of
belief,
cause we've done it a bunch on the show,
and I think I find that even for
atheists,
unbelievers,
everyone kind of gets to a point where
it's like,
all right,
well I the good ones at least get to a
point where it's like,
all right,
well that's what I believe in.
And it frames some other stuff.
So let's talk about that.
So without going too far down that
rabbit hole,
if you think that that those systems are
collapsing,
is that a,
is that really a metaphor or a or a
bridge to why so many systems seem like
they're collapsing right now?
Media politics.
I think that's exactly what's happening.
I will sit here and predict to you that
I believe in the next [inaudible]
actually,
I believe it's happening now,
but I believe it will erupt at some
point.
That there's going to be an intellectual
revival of uh,
it's,
it's really Aristotelian thought.
The idea that we're here,
we have a purpose and that bottle has a
purpose,
that this body has a purpose.
This mine has a purpose that is already
coming back.
And when you talk to people,
it's really interesting when you go in
to the top universities and you talk to
the young people there who are the best
minds of the country.
They're all believers.
They don't believe in God,
which wouldn't have been true I think 30
40 years ago.
And this is because ideas play
themselves out over time.
And this idea that the world is material
is ending.
And yes,
I think a lot of the craziness we're
seeing and that,
you know,
I hate talking about some of these
extraordinary political things because
see,
it sounds like you're being mean.
Like it sounds like when I say if a man
has an operation then turns himself into
a woman,
he's not a woman.
That's a statement of fact in my,
to my mind,
it doesn't mean that he should be abused
or bullied or hurt or anything like
that.
It's a totally different question.
But some of these questions where
reality is starting to disappear I think
are built into the fact that this idea
is collapsing.
It's so interesting because I do believe
that trans people exist.
I mean,
I mean I,
I'm not saying,
yeah,
I don't think you said that they don't
exist but,
but that I believe that it is,
it is a,
an actual,
um,
I don't want to say it's an,
it's an actual existential thing for
this particular person,
but yet I can still go with you in that
place because it seems like the hysteria
is constantly surrounding it is making
people question everything.
You know what I mean?
Like if you don't accept Trans people
the second that everyone else except
more,
not even accept them because I think
most people accept them.
But if you don't celebrate it
immediately or,
or wish for a trans child,
it's like they,
they will turn on as you're a transport.
And I think some of the things that to,
uh,
give a child a to hormone treatments or
any kind of opp operation based on some
kind of state of preference and that I
believe is abusive that I,
that I believe is wrong,
but for an adult to decide that he wants
to live his life in any way he wants.
As long as you're not hurting anybody,
it means it means nothing to me.
I mean,
it just means nothing to me.
But,
but when he says to me,
you must call me a woman,
then he is taken away my right to
experience reality as I experienced it.
And that's where he loses his rights as
this is,
this strikes me as you're sort of like a
mature Republican,
you know what I mean?
Like that's what it strikes me.
I was like,
if,
because everything you just said makes
sense within a conservative viewpoint.
Yeah.
You know,
within a libertarian conservative
viewpoint,
except there's so few conservatives
willing to say that.
What you just said.
Well,
you know,
it's funny you asked me at the very
beginning how I kept hold of some of
these principles and it didn't occur to
me until just a moment ago is we were
talking,
I'm talking about one of the things is
I'm a novelist.
I've lived most of my life writing
novels.
And when you were a novelist,
what you do is you create characters and
each one of these characters has a full
complete existence and a full,
complete justification.
Even when you're inventing the bad guy,
you realize that in his mind,
the world makes perfect sense and it,
and he makes perfect sense in that
world.
And I actually think of people that way.
You maybe that's a novelist training or
maybe you start out with that and it
turns you into a novelist.
But I actually think of people that way.
I actually think of somebody who says to
me,
I'm having this inner experience of
being alienated from my sax,
say,
or whatever,
whatever it is.
I,
you know,
that's,
that doesn't offend me.
It doesn't,
I mean,
that seems like,
I feel it might be painful and it
offends me if he says that I have to
react in a certain way or this guy has
to react by law in a certain way.
But his experience is like,
it's,
it really is part of the kind of fabric
of the world.
And I think,
I think that there has been too many
people on both sides of conflated,
what government does with how we live.
So in other words,
I've had this argument with
conservatives a lot where they'll,
they'll say,
well,
they want to legalize marijuana.
And I'll say,
she's fine.
Just don't let people drive with
marijuana,
you know?
And like what you want to poison
yourself?
I think it's bad for you,
but you know,
it's none of my business.
Go ahead.
Do you think marijuana is bad?
I do think is bad for you.
But what I've read,
it's bad for it,
but I don't use it.
So I don't really know that much about
it.
And you don't seem to want to stop
someone from using cocoon.
Why would I want to stop somebody from
using it?
Except,
except if,
if we were you,
I might say,
Dave,
you know,
I've read some articles,
not good for you,
whatever.
But then,
then you know,
it's coming from me and you can say the
vape pen,
there's not even room for the lungs.
Come on.
But this is the thing.
Government should not have the right to
approve or disapprove.
It only has the right to protect me from
you.
It shouldn't protect me from me.
If I want to throw myself off a bridge,
you know,
do I think that's right?
No,
but I should be able to throw myself off
a bridge.
What?
I shouldn't be able to do.
The best example I was using,
the seat seatbelts versus a cell phone.
You know,
when you use a cell phone in a car,
you're endangering me.
When you don't use your seatbelt,
you want to fly through the windshield.
It's none of my business.
And that I,
you know,
I,
I knew that libertarians take some
extreme crazy positions,
but in general,
free markets,
free minds seems to me that the way
forward in Canada.
So I do see the,
the freedom thing gaining traction for
sure.
Even the way that I've talked a lot,
obviously about classical liberalism and
libertarianism in all of this,
I see that now.
I see it,
I just see it in society and on social
media.
I see it more in a cooler fashion than
it would be if it was maybe coming from
Ted Cruz or something.
Like I see it's gaining a little
traction in,
in a bigger way.
And I'm not,
certainly not all because of me,
obviously.
Um,
well because of you.
But I liked what you said about that
there'll be an intellectual resurgens
too because I am starting to see a
little bit of that,
that it's starting to feel cool to have
knowledge again as opposed to the 15
years of endless reality tv and just the
worst of us constantly and endless
bickering and one upping.
I think we're starting to turn a corner
on that,
which you,
which I've been waiting for for a long
time.
It's an awful,
you know,
I recently spoke,
I don't get to speak to often,
uh,
at places bark,
partly because like ignore the request
and out.
Now I have somebody who does it,
so maybe I'll speak speaking,
I spoke at Oberlin recently,
which is a deeply like the heart of
liberal darkness and went in there and I
was,
I felt that these children who were my
age,
they now look like children.
You know,
I felt that they were being almost
abused by their heritage of,
of knowledge of wisdom was being taken
away from them.
That if,
you know,
you should come out of college,
you should have read some shakespeare.
You know,
and you should have read all of some of
the great writers.
You should know some of these great
thinkers,
Plato and people like that.
And you should know them without the
professors standing between you and the
guy.
You know,
Shakespeare has traveled through time,
400 years to bring you the wisdom,
a unique vision of the world.
I don't need a professor doing anything
but explaining the context to me,
you know,
and they have this thing called theory
and all this.
And you know,
it opened when there were,
it was a black dorm.
I mean,
Martin Luther King would roll over in
his grave,
you know,
there was,
there were kids who showed up,
uh,
you know,
kind of aggressively displaying their
sexual proclivities and then,
um,
heckling me from the crowd.
And,
and I kept saying,
you know what,
hold your question and I'm going to,
I'm going to discuss everything you want
to discuss.
And then the minute I finished and,
uh,
talking,
they ran away,
you know,
and,
and I thought,
these are that something.
It's just right there.
You know?
And,
and what was interesting was a lot of
the liberal kids who are just ordinary
little,
they state and we had really good
conversations.
Only the hecklers ran away.
Yeah.
And so I just think these kids are being
deprived.
They're being deprived of their
intellectual heritage.
They're being deprived of the idea that,
that I can't fix their problems.
What they're being told is that they're
unhappy because,
um,
they'd be unhappy because of the way I
treat them or you treat them or society
treats them.
They're unhappy because of things inside
themselves.
And then there was this,
this gay guy yelling at me the whole
time.
And at,
at one point I mentioned to somebody
else in another context that I was
actually a supporter of gay rights and
he let out this loud,
we'll thank you.
And I thought,
you know,
I thought you think people don't like it
because you're gay.
They don't like it cause you're allowed.
That's what a quality is all about.
That you just want people to be equal so
that you can treat them in a shitty is
you treat everybody else.
I don't want special treatment for being
gay and give me equal treatment and now
judge me according to exactly.
And I think this,
this is come,
you know,
I see guys like this,
a ton of Casey Coats and he writes these
letters to the sun.
You need,
you need to be made good for the sins of
the past.
What a terrible thing to tell a child.
Nobody can solve the sins of the past.
That's the whole point of the past.
It's past,
you know,
and you cannot fix the things that were
done to people.
You cannot fix history.
You can't pay people back for things
that happen to people who are dead.
You know?
That's the,
that's the tragedy of,
of a fallen world.
You know,
that,
that things are written into the fabric
of life.
And to tell somebody that,
that he's not going to be happy until he
gets paid back for slavery or whatever
it is.
It's condemning him to misery.
Yeah.
It's,
it's just sounding because it never
stops.
The payback,
the payback,
whatever it is.
There's never a moment where you go,
okay,
well we,
we got to where we're supposed to get
and now we don't need anything else
anymore.
It just,
by human logic,
it doesn't make sense.
And this used to be the question of
education.
What is the good life?
What's conducive to happiness?
What does,
you know?
What makes you miserable?
That used to be what you discussed and
it can't.
The answer can't be my happiness depends
on you.
Be Nice to me because you're going to be
what you are,
you know?
I'm curious,
what was,
what group invited you at Oberlin?
The some,
it was a bunch of Republicans who was
like the 15 republican's.
Yeah.
I kind of surprised they just wanted a
16th guy to finally show up.
They were like,
they were like trolls,
you know,
they were kind of,
they wanted me to come and make fun of
the left and I didn't.
And I thought they,
even though the whole thing wouldn't be
incredibly well,
I actually just talked about ideas and
people listened and I thought,
well,
that's a victory.
Right?
But he felt that the conservatives are
so sick of being shouted at,
that they've just turned into,
uh,
into trolls.
They want to mock the other song,
which I think is kind of interesting
because I say it all the time,
but I only get invited now to colleges
by the young Republican's are the
Libertarians and smarter students for
liberty or et Cetera,
et cetera.
All of these things that are technically
right,
even though they don't,
they don't seem to mind that I'm gay,
married and pro choice and against the
death penalty and a litany of other
things,
and then it's like,
well,
who?
Who is the tolerance side?
I don't get any invites from anyone.
No,
no young Democrats or progressives up
tomorrow,
whoever called me and been like,
Dave,
you know,
we actually see you criticizing her
side,
but let's come and talk about it.
But I'm getting a ton of love from those
other guys who by the way,
you're right.
There's a lot of trolls in that too.
They,
they've started being the funny people
too.
That's Richard.
Is that for you as a,
as a screenwriter and a guy that's
bounced between Hollywood and politics,
is that fascinating to you though?
That is starting to become funny.
It's a joy.
I mean,
I always,
my,
my joke used to be that the reason
conservatives aren't funny is because
liberals have no sense of humor,
but it is,
it is a joy to see conservatives
becoming funny and becoming the people
of freedom.
Because let's face it,
conservatism in the old style did have
its oppressive elements and it did have,
it's kind of,
uh,
you know,
when,
whenever people are in charge of the
culture,
as conservatives were until the 60s,
basically,
uh,
you know,
they abused that control.
That's part of,
that's part of power corrupting.
And there was that element in,
and there still is among conservatives
that somehow,
you know,
uh,
you are destroying the republic by not
being exactly,
you know,
a,
a Bible beating Christian or whatever it
is.
And,
and that's just largely lifted,
you know,
I mean,
so this is actually an effect,
I would say a positive effect that the
sixties revolutionist haven't
conservatives.
This is day two of loosened up.
Nobody wants to go back to wearing ties
to baseball games.
Nobody wants to go back to,
um,
you know,
uh,
a rigid life where you can't be,
look,
I,
you know,
take feminism.
Feminism right now to me,
like environmentalism is largely the
enemy.
They are,
the feminists are insane.
They're not about,
you know,
actual sexual relations between people
just like the environmentalist aren't
actually about conservation and all this
stuff,
but nobody wants to go back to a world
where a woman doesn't have,
can't choose what life she wants.
I mean,
I always say to people,
if you draw a circle that's called
individualism and a circle of is called
feminism in that place where the Venn
diagram where they meet,
you know,
I'll,
I'll agree with feminism.
Everything outside of that I don't agree
with,
but nobody wants to go back to a world
where a woman can't be fully whoever she
wants to be and nobody wants a,
certainly wants to go back to a racially
segregated world except the left.
Right.
They oddly are the ones that are pushing
these things.
Like you just described it overland and
so and so.
The,
the modern right is to some degree a
function of certain things that left
this have also brought to the table and
have now become the party of freedom.
The party of hilarity.
You know,
I mean you do not laugh a lot when you
were around leftist and when you
actually,
when you watch Samantha B on,
it's not funny.
It's not funny.
It's painful.
It's dead at that a trump.
Yeah.
You got to put it in the right and they
have to bleep it cause it's on TV.
So even if the body man,
anything to you,
you would really exciting.
Fuck yeah,
no,
this is,
this is the funny thing about it is like
when you hear them doing that,
that the cursing and the anger and the
rage and a lot of laughs there.
So then when you see,
uh,
people on the right,
so like a jeff sessions,
cause there's a lot of talk that he's
going to go in and try to close medical
marijuana dispensaries.
Now you just made it very clear you
don't smoke marijuana,
you prefer everything being equal with
people didn't for health reasons.
And I think there's a lot of debate
around that.
But I'm just going with what you said.
When you see that as a small government
guy and a state's rights guy and a,
and a libertarian,
that must be the part of the right that
you don't like.
Right?
Yeah.
I don't even know why you would bother
with that.
I mean,
I don't know why there should be medical
marijuana dispensaries.
Why shouldn't just be like a liquor
store?
You know,
you can't buy it if you're not 18 or
whatever,
the proper ages and you can't use it
behind the wheel of a car and all those
things.
And then we get to tax tax it,
you know,
and,
and get all that money.
So,
but I don't know why that should be
what's bothering him,
you know?
I mean,
I really liked jeff sessions.
I'm a pro jeff sessions guy.
I think he's going to be a great age,
you know,
I think he's going to do.
But are you concerned about that state
stuff?
Because to me that's one of the biggest
issues.
The states' rights.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
And one of the things that's kind of a
joy about the trump era is all these
liberal states suing the federal
government.
Because I think I win that either way,
either because the federal government
gets the conservative thing in there or
I win because they get states.
Right.
So,
and that's why the whole that's,
I've now been saying every week,
I mean the whole chess board is just
throwing up the traditional left right
thing barely makes sense.
It's authoritarians and Libertarians and
allies,
you know,
coming together in some interesting
spots.
I describe it as like being in a room
with a gravity has gone out of the room
and all the furniture around and you
know,
you don't know where it's gonna land.
And I understand some of these guys like
national review and even my pal Ben
Shapiro,
you know,
I understand that they're worried about
where the furniture may fall.
Uh,
I'm kind of optimistic and I'm not sure
how much of that is constitutional.
How much of the does observational,
you know?
Right.
But I do feel that good things are
coming.
I look to the generations down the line.
And what,
what I see coming up is kind of a
cultural liberalism,
which I agree with,
but,
but an understanding that freedom is
economic and freedom is governmental.
And if the government can tell you what
to like and what to do,
you know,
it's just,
it's,
it's not,
you're not free and they're not that
smart.
I'm going to give you a rare choice
here.
Do we,
do we want to go media first or trump
first from here?
This is a choose your own adventure.
It's really interesting because it's
kind of the same thing.
Let's start with trump.
All right,
let's go trump first.
So when I hear you talk about trump,
so I was with you on election night
actually.
We were,
we were at the daily wire offices and it
was me,
you and,
and Shapiro and uh,
who else do I build?
Widow was there and he was a funny night
because we were all having very mixed
emotions.
I voted for Gary Johnson.
I didn't really want either one of them
too,
when ben was alternately like thrilled
and depressed because,
you know,
but he didn't vote for trump.
But he,
Has he publicly said who we voted for
it?
I can't remember.
Yeah,
I'm not sure.
It actually comes from,
you could,
you did vote for trump.
I didn't vote for trump at the last
minute and I made this very public
decision and I explained my reasons and
all that.
Yeah.
And,
and then the fourth guy that was with
us,
Bill Whittle,
was a huge trump supporter.
And he was talking about the things that
we're talking about now that this whole
thing has been flipped in that there's
room.
Right?
Okay.
So since the election,
when I watched your videos,
you strike me as one of the only people
making any sense on trump because you
don't strike me as a,
as a pure fan boy and think that he can
go out into fifth avenue and shoot
someone.
You might turn on him for that,
but you also don't strike me as,
as just what is what most people are at
the moment,
which is just this hysterical lunacy.
Um,
just hilarious.
I,
I write columns a lot of times a PJ
media and I'll say,
well,
trump has done this right and this wrong
and I get this vicious attacks.
You know,
you're an antique trumper and they'll
let you know you're a cock cock cannot.
And then I go to work and uh,
everybody there who was kind of anti
trump yells at me for selling myself.
So I get it from all sides.
People always think we're selling
ourselves though.
Doesn't that seem odd to you?
Will people think if they disagree with
you,
your,
their reasons irrational,
your reasons or personal?
That's what they think,
right?
You're always doing it for money or for
some other reward somewhere,
but they do it just sure it's pure
intellect that has gotten them to the
whole thing,
but you don't have that intellect.
Yeah.
And so it is funny too,
cause a lot of the guys I work with are
younger than me and I always look at
them think,
do you think maybe it's occurred to me
to examine my own motos yeah.
Well that that concept though,
before we dive fully into trump,
that concept of impugning your
intellectual opponents motives.
I think it's such a sad thing that
seeped into everything and slash or,
and it doesn't teach you.
I mean there's some people obviously who
were so corrupt that it's obvious and
true,
but people are trying to find their way.
Most people in you know,
in the middle are trying to find their
way.
So trump.
Okay,
so,
so make some sense out of trump.
Okay.
What are the people that voted for
trump?
Because I genuinely thought that Hillary
Clinton was a threat to the American
experiment.
I mean,
I'm not over I that I usually don't talk
in those big terms,
but she did not believe in free speech
or hatred of the citizens.
United ruling was just indicated to me
that she believed the speech should be
controlled.
There are four justices on the supreme
court who have signed onto a theory of
the first amendment that says
essentially that it does not guarantee
you the right to speak.
What it guarantees is that the
government should control speech so that
our values continue to be upheld.
That's a very dangerous,
sick,
stupid and wrong theory.
One more judge,
I don't believe all of them would sign
on everything,
but one more judge.
And that obviously there was an open
seat and we could have lost the first
amendment.
I don't believe that was the most likely
thing,
but it could have happened.
So can you take the counterpoint on
that,
just just for devil's advocate,
the people that would argue against you
on,
on citizens united?
Well,
oh,
well,
citizens united just says that if you
form a corporation,
if you and I form the Reuben clave
corporation,
we don't lose our right to free speech.
I mean,
what happened was citizens united put
out a documentary against Hillary and
they said,
well that's campaigning so you can't put
it on the air.
And they said,
it's free speech.
We can.
And they said,
well,
you're a corporation so you don't have
the rights in the New York Times signed
onto that.
The New York Times said,
no,
we are a corporation has free speech
because we were oppressed corporation.
But your corporation does not have,
you know,
it's nuts and that's,
it's typical of the left because as I
say,
I believe their,
their reasons,
their logic is collapsing.
So they have to shout you down.
They can invite they've Ruben to Oberlin
there,
you know,
to,
to talk with the left.
They can't because they know their
argument is over.
So I voted for trump,
5% of my mind and in my mind 5% I was
thinking the guy's Hitler,
you know,
there's a 5% chance I am making the
biggest mistake of my life and I'm
pretty high percentage.
If you're going Hitler,
you know your apps.
When when Reagan was elected,
I remember having friends called me up
and saying,
is this the end?
I said,
no,
he's a good guy.
You know,
it will be fine.
I'll be on the other side for a while.
You know,
you,
you will die when people call me up with
this.
I was going like 95% and I think,
you know,
like,
like you said,
that's a big percentage if you're
talking a genuine authoritarian tire.
I just thought the bet was worth it
because I thought that Hillary was the
end of the American experiment in the
piece fullest possible way.
Like,
you know,
they,
there's something in sports called
losing comfortably where you don't even
notice you're losing and then the game
is over and it's done.
That's what I thought she was.
And,
and so I thought that it was worth the
risk and I have been largely delighted
with how good he's been.
Now.
That doesn't mean I think he's been
great.
It just means that I was really worried
that he was going to be really bad and
instead he's been pretty good,
you know,
um,
crazy things about him that are hard to
get over the mean tweets,
the personal tweets,
you know,
all that.
So I don't mind that.
I don't mind the mean tweets,
but,
but I'll,
I'll tell you like three things that he
has done that have really lifted me,
you know what I mean?
Like I really just felt like,
wow,
I did.
Obviously Gorsuch,
that's the obvious one.
I mean that's a big deal.
And and people who on the right who
don't like trump keeps saying,
oh you keep bringing up gorsuch.
I'm going to keep bringing it up,
but until I'm gone,
you know that's a big,
big supreme court appointment and he did
a great job.
It's also kind of a funny one to
diminish regardless of what side you're
on because guess what,
the supreme courts are a third of the
government.
That's right.
That's one of the brands you left has
been using them as a super legislature
and of course it won't do that.
He said opposed to that.
The other one,
and this is a little wonky of me,
but I've been,
I was talking about a way before the
election,
so I feel I come by,
it naturally is he's been rolling back
regulations and we were talking about
this before,
the idea that you need a permit to get
your to be a hairstylist permit to sell
lemonade on the street.
You know,
he's been rolling that back and there
was a deal,
luge that was Obama's kind of,
you know,
uh,
Parthian shot as he was leaving office.
He just left all these regulations in
place and he's been repealing them.
And I think that that is a huge deal.
The regulatory state is a genuine threat
to our freedoms.
You know,
just the fact that you need,
you need to ask permission of the
government to do anything,
uh,
is a bad thing.
And that's to me,
I mean,
it really is a really,
is uplifting to me.
And the third thing,
and this is why I wanted to talk about
trump first,
is that he has driven a truck into the
structure of a corrupt,
biased,
intellectually poisonous media.
And it was rotten.
The structure was rotten.
But he's the one who drove the truck
into it.
And I don't think anybody else had the
charisma or the viciousness or,
uh,
or the UN or that understanding that
comes from being a TV star to do what he
has done.
So I'm with Ya.
Yeah.
Especially on that one.
I liked the regulations also.
I,
this is somewhere where I have shifted a
little bit.
Right.
I get it now the government regulations
that these nonsensical things and you
know,
as a small business owner,
I so understand those types of things
now.
Um,
but that last one to me is the one
that's really resonating with people.
Even the way you just said it.
And that's the one that is catching fire
with people and that's the one that I
think really most people just,
it just intuitively they understand.
Do you think he truly truly got it right
from the beginning?
Do you think that really all came from
him?
Uh,
that's the part,
you know,
I said before the action,
I just don't know what his moral center
is.
I still don't know what like his real
sort of the ethos of this man is.
Do you think he really,
really understood that?
Like that was just from being an
outsider and mocked at the old White
House press correspondence things and
being on reality TV in New York media
and all that.
I think he got it because he's,
then he's one of them,
you know,
he's like,
I mean me too.
I was a reporter,
I was in radio news and all this stuff
and I would see what was going on and
how people thought and how,
you know when you're surrounded by
people who agree with you,
you become biased on,
I think he's just,
he's,
he's got a talent for it.
He's got a talent for,
you know,
I used to talk to Andrew Breitbart and I
would sit there and go like,
I've never heard somebody who
understands the flow of information that
is going to be here at this moment at 12
o'clock and it's to be here at two
o'clock and it's going to hear three
guns.
This is the way it's gonna work trumps
not like that.
He has a natural genius for
understanding the flow of information.
Sometimes he will do,
it'll send out a tweet and everybody
would say,
why did he distract everybody from,
and he did.
He realized that he was losing control
of the narrative and you seized it back.
And does he do that?
Like sit up in his own,
mount a white and say,
Aha,
now it 10,
12,
15.
I kind of doubt it.
I don't know him,
so I don't know.
But I think he has a natural feeling for
the way this works and he understands,
you know,
he'd be a fool not to understand that
he's under fire unfairly.
Uh,
and,
and I think he knows how to fight back
and it's a pleasure to watch.
All right,
so trump drives a truck through this
thing,
right?
I like what has happened there and we're
going to get to that and seeing that in
a moment,
but let's talk about that 5%.
Do you still fear that 5% or have those
fears been allayed just because time has
gone on and you haven't seen anything
that observed,
they have been a lead to almost almost
entirely everything that I thought about
trump,
it turned out to be true in terms of my
assessment of his personality,
but none of it turned out to be its
worst manifestation.
So it,
it really did bother me,
for instance,
that he would use violent language at
rallies a punch.
This guy,
if you see that Guy Punch him in the
face and all that stuff and he does have
that side to his personality,
but it didn't manifest itself in,
in actual violence or act.
You know,
he's the opposite of an authoritarian.
If you consider the fact that one of the
most incompetent parts of his imagined
of his administration is he has been
unable to fill a lot of the positions in
the,
in the government,
in the permanent government.
He hasn't taken over the permanent
government,
which is what in the thor and actual
authoritarian were.
Do you know an actual Hitlerian figure
would come in and make sure he made all
the appointments and put his guys in
there.
He's too lazy to do that because that
lazy though.
Or is that just a function of heat?
Cause there is some,
some reason to believe he's just having
trouble getting the right type of
capital.
I think that he probably is having
trouble with is he,
you know,
he has this unfortunate habit.
One of his really unfortunate habits of
wrong footing his own people.
So you'll go out and you'll say,
well,
president trump said this and he'll say,
I didn't say that.
And you get stabbed in the back by your
own guy.
And I think a lot of people don't want
to sign on for that.
He's,
he's erratic and he is emotional.
And I think that that's dangerous for
the,
you know,
the best people that said,
he has appointed a tremendous cabinet.
I mean unbelievable cabinet and the
cabinet of people who are at odds with
the agencies that they are appointed to
lead,
which I think is part of my hatred of,
of uh,
regulation agency and regulation.
So when you see things like,
so something like that,
the Paris climate accords,
I suspect that you are fine with us
getting thrilled.
I think it's nonsense.
Nonsense in that it was nonbinding.
And so I think that we had to burden the
load or I,
yeah,
I think the Paris accords were only
going to get us into legal trouble.
There were only there so people could
sue us.
There was nothing binding about it.
But it would give a lot of legal
problems to the government.
And I also believe that global warming
as it's posed,
I,
you know,
I'm not saying that the world isn't
getting warmer,
I'm just saying that global warming
isn't hysterical.
Environmental disaster.
Uh,
I,
I'm almost positive it's a nonsense.
Where,
where do you go for information on,
on global warming?
Cause this is one of the ones where I
find that when I'm talking to
conservatives and where I know that
there's so much ground to agree on some
stuff that I do believe in climate
change I would do,
I wouldn't eat,
we don't even have to call it global
warming.
Climate Change.
Um,
well the very fact they changed it to
climate change from global warming tells
her this argument.
Here's the thing.
I mean,
we're on a rock.
The spiraling into an atomic explosion.
It's not a steady state is not a,
it's not a secure environment.
We're not living.
And we've gone from ice ages to,
you know,
a love of the world being basically
molten,
you know,
as I mean,
the climate changes.
So we know the climate is changing and
we know it's gotten more and more over
the years.
I mean,
you know,
you're going back in time.
There were years when the Thames froze
and that,
you know,
and people skated on the Thames and so
like we know that there's,
there's changes.
There is no way to a know how much of
this is human endeavor and,
and be to know how much,
how this goes into the future.
When people say science,
there is no science for predicting the
future.
There is no science for predicting the
When people are telling you what's going
to happen in the future,
they are what's coming out of their
mouth is nothing.
Okay.
When people say this is what's going to
happen 10 years down the line,
I have arguments like this about
politics too.
And somebody says,
well if we do this then in four years
and go like ass,
stop sovereign right there I go,
I'll give you until Thursday.
And then you're right.
You know,
I mean,
well I love that because every time they
show anything that worked well the CBO
said that in 10 years this is going to
cost 20 million lives.
They like,
has that ever happened?
They're always doing this.
And by the way,
you're the same people who got
everything wrong before the election and
now you suddenly can prognosticate.
Perfect.
And when you hear the phrase,
if present trends continue,
it's like everything after that is
nonsense because that never happens
either.
You're right.
So all right,
so without,
without getting too far into the climate
change thing,
do you think there's some role for
government to play with dealing with
other nations when it comes to climate
and that I can't think of anything.
I mean,
except like,
you know,
I,
I do believe in preserving our
environment and taking care of things.
Yeah.
You know,
this is the thing is the left always
takes these rational issues where
there's a true good to be gained and
they turned them into hysteria.
So give us all your power.
I mean,
look,
I'm a religious guy.
If a guy comes on TV and says Jesus is
coming tomorrow unless you send me a
check,
I get suspicious.
Right.
But so when these guys say to me,
if you don't give the government all
power and essentially fulfill every
socialist need,
the world is going to be destroyed in a
hail of fire.
I feel the same way.
It's like yeah,
I'll turn on something else and see if
there's an old Yogi Berra rerun on her,
which there usually you go up into the
really high channel.
It's like around one 30 or so.
Uh,
okay.
Let's talk about the media.
Okay.
Cause cause you can talk about,
we can talk ourselves into a trump
style.
Yes.
Fidget spinner and not going to get us
anywhere.
So uh,
the media,
he drove this truck through it.
I do think it's great.
I think it's helped voices like yours,
like what we're doing here.
Like many other people who are not
promising all the answers but at least
promising discussions and,
and some,
some lines of thought that maybe weren't
getting out there in the mainstream.
Do you think that there is a risk in
that too?
That we are just going to filter
ourselves into oblivion to the point
where instead of having three news
channels,
we're now going to have a good Gillian
of them and we're all going to hate each
other for a zillion new and reasons that
we didn't even realize that.
Definitely there's a definite moral
hazard here.
I mean a free,
you know,
as,
as these liars and our press keeps
saying a free press is important to a
free society.
And you do want,
I mean,
another thing that's working well under
trump is that everybody,
that the pressers attacking the people
in power instead of what they did during
the Obama administration where they kept
their hands over their eyes and said,
oh look,
he's scandal free.
I would argue there's a little bit of an
overcorrection happened and
overcorrection no question about it.
But that's because they're so corrupt.
I mean,
that's why.
So I do believe in,
uh,
a,
I can't remember the word,
but a press that basically stands up to
power.
I do believe in a free press.
We don't have a free press.
We have a press that has been corrupted
beyond its purposes.
And that doesn't mean they're no good
reporters.
That means that a good reporter on the
New York Times is basically doing the
wrong thing because he's giving credence
and uh,
he's given credence and credibility to a
sophomore,
Eric Left Wing College magazine,
and with his,
can you give an example of that?
Because that's the type of thing.
So I attack CNN all the time.
I've seen some bad stuff lately out of
the New York Times where the headline
leads you one way and then when you read
it,
it really isn't what it said.
They've been doing a lot of corrections
lately,
which usually no one reads the
correction.
So you never see any of that.
But when I,
when I do attack the New York Times,
people would give me more shit.
Like CNN.
It's like everyone's in on the joke now,
but New York Times it's a little bit
different.
So when you describe it as a,
as a sophomore,
oh,
there,
I mean if you read their op Ed page,
which I now call knucklehead row,
you know,
if you read their op ed page,
really is like a bunch of eight year old
girls in a room where a mouse has gotten
loose.
And so they're all screaming and
yelling,
everybody running around in hysterics.
And,
and that's really unfair to eight year
old girls.
And if you read,
I mean,
just yesterday they ran a story of
Donald Trump jr met with a Russian
lawyer and all this.
Who Cares?
I mean,
who cares?
Donald Trump jr met with a Russian
lawyer to get info because he thought
she had information on the opposition
and everybody,
you know,
faints and who cares?
I saw celebrities,
well known people think this is it.
This is the collusion we've been looking
for.
It's a panic.
It's called story.
It's called opposition research.
Everyone does this.
Do you think Hillary didn't meet with
people to see if they had information on
trump and only in an organization where
no one is sitting next to you who says,
dude,
that's not a story.
That's a 30 page,
30 story.
Only in a place where everybody thinks
we've found the smoking gun.
Can you make a fool of yourself like
that?
You know?
In other words,
you want somebody to say to you,
you know,
like,
I know you're a conservative,
but there is some thing to not letting
people starve to death in the streets
and go,
oh yeah,
from out of it.
You okay then the opposite is true,
you know?
Yeah.
I know you were a left winger,
but everybody does oppo research and you
know,
the fact that she was from Russia and
makes it doesn't mean a thing.
You know?
And by the way,
as far as I know,
he didn't buy anything from you or take
anything from her.
It was a ruse to get them to talk about
this ruling.
You know,
that limits the way they can use banks
and all this stuff.
I,
you know,
we'd been listening to this stupid story
for six months,
this Russian story.
It is not a story.
I mean,
it's just not,
and even,
even the Russian meddling with the
election,
which I believe happened,
is kind of like finding a spy.
You know,
we go,
oh my goodness,
there's a spy who would ever spy on a
call,
you know,
uh,
can we bring our spies back for a couple
of,
you know,
that that's what this is.
Like,
we do it to them and all this,
and they do it to us.
So the New York Times has become,
it's dishonest and it,
they use good reporters in good
reporting to tell a dishonest story.
And the fact that they think that they
even can conceive of the idea that
they're not a leftist rag shows you how
far gone they are.
I mean,
that they cannot,
you know,
Eh,
take it any day,
pick up the Wall Street Journal and pick
up the New York Times and the Wall
Street Journal.
You're talking to an adult,
the New York Times,
you're talking to a child.
Well,
it's interesting that you made a point
of saying the op Ed page,
it's too,
because obviously you expect opinion
that's separate than the editorial side,
but he,
but their app aid page,
the reaction to some of the things that
they're doing has gotten insane.
So they brought Bret Stevens from the
Wall Street Journal.
He writes that one piece basically just
about skepticism.
It didn't even really say he doesn't
believe in climate change.
Right.
I think you may have even said the
opposite.
But then there were immediately people
demanding he be fired and all of this
craziness just for having an alternate
opinion on their op Ed page.
But the one that I thought was more
interesting,
do you see the one a couple of weeks
ago,
uh,
about uh,
Bret Weinstein from evergreen state and
it was all about campus free speech.
But basically the thrust of it at the
end was we as liberal as better there
are caring about this because it's
coming for us.
Right.
And I thought,
what an odd admission you,
you are now admitting that you didn't
care about free speech because it was
coming about coming against the other
[inaudible].
Right now it's finally turning on a guy
who's left,
left,
super progressive.
So now we better start caring.
Like that was strange.
Admitted it was a nice,
it was refreshing.
I suppose it is,
but I mean I think the New York Times
was just gone so far down this hole that
uh,
an article like that stands out.
You know,
when you read an article like that and
the Times you go like,
wow,
even in the New York Times there now for
free speech,
you know,
that's,
that's not good.
You know,
like in the New York Times should be for
free speech every day for everyone.
Every day.
The New York Times should have
conservatives on,
on the desks where the news decisions
are being made.
You know,
the,
the Wall Street Journal is,
is anti trump and its news pages
sometimes unfairly,
I think,
but not crazily.
You know,
they have people obviously correcting
their opinions.
You know,
that comes a level that comes a time
when the level of corruption gets so bad
that audacity becomes a kind of a brag.
So you see this in governments all the
time.
You see it in Illinois,
places like Chicago and things like this
where remember the,
the uh,
uh,
boss tweed and the little tin box and
all this stuff,
put the money in a little tin box.
This corruption is,
this is,
this comes from a sense that we are so
corrupt that no one can touch us.
Okay?
When you put George Stephanopoulos,
a Clinton hack at the top of your news
team,
he is your news guy.
That's a sign that you have become
corrupt.
It's not that he's at ABC news that's
ABC,
has not,
not that he's not a nice man or whatever
he is.
He's a guy who once said to Hillary,
I love you hillary.
He can have a role in your news
department,
but he should not be running in your
news department,
the guy at CBS.
So who just looks like Ted Baxter to me.
You remember from the buyer isn't Scott
Pelley who may,
who made decisions so bias during the
Obama administration that his own
reporters didn't want their stories
going on his air because they didn't
want to do what I was talking about with
serve a biased report.
This corruption has becomes so manifest
and so absurd that to see it taken down
is a beautiful thing.
But you're right,
we need to replace it with something of
value.
We need to replace it with something
that works.
So is that why they're hitting back so
hard?
So the CNN thing that happened last week
with this threat to docs,
this person who did an perfectly legal
thing,
it is legal to make means,
by the way,
he didn't make it for trump.
However,
it got to trump,
and it sounds like it was actually a
slightly altered version,
right?
We don't know how it is,
but there are millions of people making
means on the Internet as we sit here.
Right.
The second,
it wasn't just that they were
threatening to dox this guy for doing
something illegal.
It was the line after that where they
said,
he's agreed not to do this offensive,
blah,
blah.
Again,
as if they're the church or his parents
or something.
So it,
to me that was,
that was the scarier thing,
not the threat of the docs,
which of course is wrong,
but the threat that they were tacitly
saying or implicitly saying to everybody
else,
we're,
we're watching you two and we're going
to come for all of them.
Well,
you know,
the Internet turned on them in a
beautiful fashion,
right?
And,
but it was only the,
the followup and the completion of the
logic that went after joe the plumber.
And of course the right mishandled that
by elevating joe the plumber to some
kind of commentator because he'd been
attack.
But remember Joe,
the plumber went out and asked the
question of a political candidate and he
went after the Chi West.
The question,
I mean,
this is what the,
how corrupt they've become.
And they are thuggish and this is all of
them.
This is,
I mean,
I'm talking about the networks.
I'm talking about the times,
I'm talking about Wapo and I'm talking
about CNN,
which is in some ways the least of them
because it's just a small operation that
would vanish like that.
If people cut their cable cords,
you know?
Right,
right.
They say,
what's that thing?
They say that if they would get cnn at
airports,
it would lose.
Like they would lose all of his,
all of his viewers do.
You know,
it's all of these guys and and they
hate,
it hasn't even occurred to one of them.
Not one of them has said,
well,
you know,
trump is being a jerk and trump is not,
it's not fair what he does.
It's really wrong when he attacks our
reporter in terms of her face or
whatever,
you know,
like,
but he has a point,
you know,
we need to reform our industry.
There's a reason that the people believe
Donald Trump more than they believe us.
There's a reason that people hate us so
much.
So it really is that they've just been
drunk on power.
Yeah.
These last,
whatever it is,
30 years,
they'd been drunk on power for so long
and now they finally have someone
throwing it in their face.
And now the people,
the actual people that are rising up
against them to that.
And I saw,
uh,
you saw probably Chris Cuomo,
who of course his brother is the mayor
or the governor,
he's a yard one.
He said his father was the governor of
New York.
He's an idiot.
He's like Fredo from the,
he really,
I mean,
I,
every time you see the guys,
just another,
just embarrassed,
but he tweeted something about these
hateful means and should we release the
information because the guys tweeted
some other races and stuff and all that.
And then he ended up deleting it.
But I,
I retweeted him and I said,
would you say that a meme or a Gif is
worse than what then Linda Sarsour
calling for a jihad?
Now,
we talked about it briefly before we
started,
but regardless of whether she meant her
own personal jihad,
but she's talking about the white
supremacists and Islamophobia in the
White House.
And everyone knows if you're using that
word,
you're trying to gin up a certain
something.
And My tweak got way more retweets and
everything then than any of his due.
He has a million followers and almost no
interaction,
which also tells you a little something.
Um,
but I bring this up because it's like,
of course he doesn't respond because
they think they're beholden to nobody to
where it's like we're,
but we actually are beholden to our
audience.
You know,
when I was a newspaper man was a
newspaper man in a small town with a
very powerful and somewhat corrupt
sheriff.
So it was like out of a movie,
you know,
and I would do,
I would batch it again.
And I remember saying to one,
I had some sources in the department and
I remember saying to one of them,
look,
we work for,
we both worked for the people.
And he turned around and he said,
I work with are the people you work for
a corporation?
And I thought,
my God,
he's right.
He said,
that's true.
That's true.
They don't understand that.
They're just mouthpieces for big
corporations,
which love big government because big
government hurts the little guy,
you know,
that's all they're doing.
They're just standing up for these
powerful corporations in the name of all
the leftist,
you know,
uh,
by words and all this stuff.
You know,
they really have lost any real sense of
themselves.
And it's just,
it's,
it's pitiful to watch in some ways,
but it is good to see it getting
exposed.
And what I would like to see on the
right,
I feel on the right,
we have a lot of really good people like
you and me and Ben and all these people
expressing opinions.
But we,
I don't consider myself part of the
right kind of moving into libertarian.
I would say,
you know,
I'm,
I'm still a liberal,
which is a fine line between that and a
libertarian.
But yes,
I,
I hate to even pause you there to say
that,
but I know a certain amount of people
start screaming.
But I considered my,
I'm more than happy to talk to all you
guys,
but I say it all the time that I'm a
conservative because I'm alone.
I'll just give it varies on that.
Okay.
Yeah.
And I,
I think that I would like to see us
start to gather information and,
and that's expensive and you need people
to back you when you needed to somehow
make it profitable.
But we need to start sending people to
the hotspots because for me to get the
facts,
I have to go to the New York Times and
the Wall Street Journal and CNN and all
these places cause they hire reporters
and it's opinions are great and insights
are great and there is now because the
press is so corrupt,
there is an actual need for people like
us to say,
they're telling you the facts mean this,
but the facts actually might mean this,
you know,
that is an actual profession now as a
real profession that needs to be done.
But I would like to see the right go
after have people in Iraq have people
in,
uh,
you know,
in the hotspots of the world,
have people in Washington DC,
the best news program on television as
Brett bears special report because they
gather news and because they're fair,
even though he's,
you know,
even though they tilt to the right,
they're very fair about what they cover.
Are you shocked by the breadth of it?
Just sort of the amount of activists
masquerading as journalists because
that's what I think they are truly,
these people are not,
I mean,
I've seen just some of the recent hit
pieces on me.
Yeah.
And it's like,
no matter how much I plead my case or
defend myself or show them evidence to
the contrary of what,
uh,
you know,
some mother Jones calling me and
extremist to the right of Breitbart.
Wow.
Real doozy.
And it's like,
you know,
they,
they don't correct anything.
They don't care.
They know their job is safe and it's
like forgetting all that you are not a
journalist.
That's what I,
I tweeted the guys something to that
effect.
Like,
I just want you to admit,
you're not a journalist,
right?
Right.
What you want,
even though I probably had a decent case
for liable,
right?
What you want,
but can you admit what you're doing?
And it's like that sort of,
that lack of self awareness.
You know,
I,
I've been,
I have now been saying this to the right
for 10,
15 years about our loss of the culture.
And that's what this is.
This is the result of our loss of the
universities,
of our loss of TV stations.
You know,
uh,
women's magazines.
Every woman's magazine is left wing.
Every comedian on television,
every late night comedian,
every single one is a left winger,
not one,
not one woman.
And when,
and when one of them made a joke was
nice to Donald Trump,
he was basically pilloried,
you know,
he had to take Jimmy Fallon,
Jimmy Fallon.
That was the one.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's hard to tell the difference because
they're all the same,
you know,
they're all,
exactly,
how do we,
how did we let that happen?
Then why don't we respond?
And I always do.
I always say to conservatives that
telling them about the culture is like
trying to explain to my wife when she
buys something on sale,
it's still costs money.
Had you always looks at me and he goes
and says,
you know,
you're a cute guy and I like you but I
don't know what you're talking about.
And that's the way conservatives look at
me.
You know,
like how did we get to the point where
we have people talking like a 100 year
old men go on,
I don't go to the movies anymore.
I just turn on,
turn our clouddam Doris stays good
enough,
you know?
I mean,
that's insane.
And how do we get to the point where we
start making stuff that educates people
not to be right wingers but simply to
open their minds a little bit.
So I don't know what your feelings are
on Milo,
but I suspect that after hearing you say
that you must at least love much of the
movement behind him because he isn't he
that isn't that thing that you're now
saying we got,
we were winning the culture war back.
I mean,
he talked about that all the time right
here.
You know,
that is such a great question.
It really is.
It's a great question because Milo gives
me fits.
Uh,
I've only spoken to Milo once.
We had a long conversation about video
games.
He was when he was on Gamergate and,
um,
and I liked the men,
you know what I mean?
I got along with him.
He has done some stuff that's so
vicious,
partly to my friend Ben Shapiro,
which I resent because he's my friend,
um,
an antisemitic and,
and he's given,
given shelter to Antisemites,
which I always feel the minute,
dice minute,
I see antisemitism.
It is the canary in the coal mine.
You know,
that's where like evil dwells basically.
I usually go for the,
for it,
go for the Jews first and like,
so there's stuff that he's done that I
just think it's great and I wish that he
would,
uh,
you know,
find himself in a somewhat better place
because there is such a thing.
Even though I believe everyone should be
allowed to speak.
There are some things that are,
that when spoken or reprehensible,
you know what I mean?
So,
well,
there's,
there's consequences for your speech.
That's right.
You know,
and when I hear him,
uh,
you know,
I don't know the June remarks and the,
and the kind of,
um,
the,
the kind of hateful,
allowing hatefulness to be cute,
allowing it to be ironic saying,
you know,
I've heard him say,
for instance,
I've heard him say when,
when our generation is antisemitic,
they're just being ironical.
I think like,
yeah,
that's a snake that's going to bite
back.
You know,
I don't,
I don't really buy into that.
And,
and so I like what he's doing.
I don't always like the way that he's
doing it or what he's doing it in
service to.
But certainly when he had what was
called the dangerous faggot tour,
yeah,
I laughed out loud.
I thought I wanted more of those guys.
I mean,
that was bright,
bright.
Bart and I used to have this
conversation all the time.
You know,
when I first met Breitbart,
he kind of enlisted me into the La,
right as he did.
Almost all of us.
Uh,
you know,
I said to him,
I want to tell you right upfront that
I'm not going in for this gay stuff
because of this anti gay stuff cause I
think we're going to lose.
I said,
hey,
we're going to lose,
which has no shame but we're going to
lose and be wrong.
And that's a shame.
That's really shameful.
Breitbart said to me,
what I want is more patriotic gay porn.
I said,
sign me up.
Two straight guys demanding more
patriotic that how much of the country
we're going to watch it.
But you know,
and,
and so I think that,
uh,
you know,
I have this conversation with people
about Milo all the time.
I see a good that he is doing.
I see dangers in the way he's doing it.
And I think you can be too about too
much because there is moral universe and
you do not want to,
you didn't want to blow yourself through
it.
Do you think that's kind of the fast and
bargain that you have to play?
You're getting what you want,
what you've wanted here,
and you as a guy that's been through the
Hollywood machine too,
so you're,
you're getting the culture wins that
really,
if he had,
let's say he had done,
you know,
been a little more careful with his
language or not done some of the
unnecessary over the top stuff or
whatever that it might have.
Uh,
it might've shaved some of the good part
that you want.
Yeah.
Maybe,
maybe just wouldn't have broke through
with his name.
That's kind of what the trump,
the trump,
ian bargain.
I was only a guy as uncaring about the
niceties would have driven his truck
into the media the way he did.
And I think that,
does it come with moral hazards?
Yes.
To people have to speak up about those
moral hazards and take the flack from
the right when they say,
you know,
oh you're a cock and you're all these
things.
Yes we have to take that flag but it has
to be done because I think we had
reached a tipping point.
I hate to use a cliched phrase like
that,
but I think we had reached a tipping
point where we were sounding very much
like a communist country.
Like there was things that you could say
that made you persona non grata that
there were opinions.
You can have that,
you know,
the trap door,
like the James Bond villain drop through
the trap door.
I think we were in a dangerous point.
And if we end political correctness is a
smothering toxic,
uh,
evil device for making the lines seemed
like a virtue.
And if Donald Trump destroys political
correctness,
he will have done a great thing.
I mean,
a great thing.
And that,
that has moral hazards come along with
that.
I think we shouldn't forget it.
And you know,
a good example of this was when they
shut down Shakespeare on the park the
other day.
Now Shakespeare that was reprehensible
to assassinate the president or onstage.
I really think,
you know,
as a,
as a Shakespeare Fan,
I think that it was a,
an awful,
awful thing to do.
But they would have done the same thing
if it was Obama,
right?
Yeah.
But to shut them down and to have my
friends,
you know,
writing that this was a good thing.
You know that that's a mistake.
I completely agree because now what
you're saying,
it's okay to fight to say,
well we've got to be as tough as the
left,
but to say we've got to be as tough as
the left for things that the left would
approve of like shutting down free
speech.
That doesn't make any sense to me.
And that's why he both,
and that's why again,
these sides,
the sides are just becoming meaningless
and nonsense science.
I think that that's a really good
observation because I do think that I,
and I,
I,
this is part of the problem I have with
the right right now is I keep saying to
them,
you know,
you're right there.
They're disturbed because the
conservative movement has essentially
collapsed when trump swept all those
guys off the stage,
the way he did and the primaries,
the conservative movement was done for.
And my response to that is fix it.
You know,
put it back together differently.
get,
it's a new world,
make a new conservative conservatism.
You don't have to get rid of your
principles.
You don't have to get rid of your big
principles,
but you might have to get rid of some of
the ways those principles express
themselves in the world.
Yeah.
So is that just,
that's just real politic,
right?
I mean,
it seems to be here,
you're just viewing the world as it is,
not as you want it to be.
So if you,
if you had a guy like,
uh,
like bill kristol where it's like he
wants that conservative thing to exist
again,
I don't think you can make that happen
or you certainly can't.
It's going to go through several other
iterations before it was ever to get
back to something like that.
Yeah,
no,
I'm interested in guys like Henry Olsen
who are basically saying,
pointing out that Reagan was kind of an
Fdr Democrat more than anything else and
he invented the kind of modern
conservatism I,
I'm interested in guys who say,
look,
this is the field of play and this is
where we want to get.
See,
this is,
this is the thing that I know that I
notice a lot of commentators don't.
I know where I want to get.
I want to get to more freedom.
I have more freedom now six months after
the election of Donald Trump,
seven months after the election of
Donald Trump than I did eight months
ago.
No question.
In my mind,
the fact that the EPA can't now rule my
sink a waterway and declare that they
can now tell me whether I can shave or
not.
You know,
I think that that makes me more free.
I think judge [inaudible] that being
said,
trump may not be great on eminent
domain,
right?
Because he might want this wall to cut
through things.
You know,
who knows where that will the walls at
now.
But I assure you he would have no
problem using eminent domain to make a
cut through.
Yeah,
no,
there,
there are all these dangers involved and
so I just want to see as the ball moving
in the freedom direction all the time.
And right now it is.
And you know,
I definitely see moral hazards.
I definitely look at it.
Got a Milo.
I mean he's such a good example cause I
look at him and they're things that he
does that I make me laugh out loud and I
just think it's wonderful.
He's here and then suddenly he'll say
something and I'll think,
except we don't want it.
You don't want to give credence to
hatred and evil.
You know,
I mean it evil,
evil is bigger than irony and evil will
eat irony,
you know?
And so you want to be careful about
that.
I don't know.
I feel that that could have been the
ending,
but I'm gonna I'm gonna ask you one
other thing,
which is do you fear perhaps that these
forces which have grown so fat and it
were so drunk on their own power and all
that,
now that it's starting to crumble,
do you fear that they will hit back on
people like you and people like me and
whoever in a way that we made don't,
we may not understand yet.
In other words,
that,
that thing that they did with the Han
asshole solo and the Gif,
where are the meme was uh,
a warning shot only of the way that
they're going to try to treat the people
who go against them.
I think we've seen it with these leaks
from the intelligence community about
Donald Trump did this and they turned
out some of those leaks turned out not
to be true,
but the press was perfectly happy to say
sources within the intelligence
community,
former officials,
and you think,
well,
what does a former official,
no,
it didn't matter.
They were putting on a front page.
That was the front page on the New York
Times,
The Washington Post.
They were,
that was the deep state striking back.
There's no question about it.
They're going to continue to fight.
This is a genuine battle.
This is a genuine battle for,
uh,
you know,
I hate to say it,
but it's a battle for the future.
I mean,
I think that this global world,
which has many good things in it,
I think free trade and global
communication and all of this also
allowed a small group of people to make
decisions on unelected people to make
decisions for,
for people who had no way to redress
their grievances.
And I think that that can't be,
you know,
if we're going to become a global world,
then I want America to take it over that
basically,
I'm an imperialist in that regard.
If we,
if the world's gonna be global,
fine,
but everybody's living under the
constitution,
you know,
that's the way it's going to be.
If not,
if everybody's not living under the
constitution in Saudi Arabia,
doesn't want to live under the
constitution than I want Saudi Arabia to
stay in Saudi Arabia and I want Saudi
Arabians to stay in Saudi Arabia unless
they want to come over here to live
under the constitution.
So those are the choices.
You know what I mean?
That's an interesting way to frame it.
There's a global world run by the
Constitution or America first.
Well,
Andrew,
a anonymous source on Capitol Hill.
He's telling me right now that this was
an excellent interview.
Oh,
it's always a pleasure to talk to you.
I hope we can continue the conversation.
You know,
I get my,
my anonymous sources.
I've got to the US from Gloria Borger.
She's always quoting this anonymous,
like you talking to the janitor,
like source on capital.
It's anybody.
That's what I want people to understand.
It's all made up.
It's been a pleasure as always.
And for more on Andrew,
check him out on the Andrew Klavan show.
Brilliant name,
by the way,
where you know,
it was amazing.
We worked for ages on it.
The Andrew Klavan show.
It's right here on the youtube.